in the lobby of Ramsey solutions and be
stopped by from Canada welcome to
Nashville Andy how are you well thank
you for having me
cool how can I help today well I'm a
certified financial planner in Canada
and I've often heard you say a number of
times that the behavior is more
important than the math in a lot of
financial planning areas I know for the
debt snowball you say lists at small as
the largest right rather than the
highest interest rate to the lowest
interest rate because people need the
victories along the way and that sort of
thing what other areas in financial
planning would you say the behavior is
more important than the math it's a
really good question because in your
world a certified financial planning and
the world that I came from similar you
know I've got a formal academic degree
in finance we're taught to be numbers
crunchers that's right and most of us
are detailed people and we we really
like math and we really get into the
numbers and want to crunch those things
and I almost had to overcome that to
help people transform their lives
financially I don't it's not that I
don't believe in math I do cuz I'm a
math nerd by my nature it's how God
wired me but sometimes in the financial
arena that you're in and that I've been
in most of my life we we try to fix
things with a behavior I mean with a
math problem and it's not a math problem
it's a behavior problem so I appreciate
your question a lot especially coming
from where you're coming from
so yeah the debt snowball mathematically
doesn't work but it works because it's
behavior and all the studies have shown
that people when they try to do it
mathematically correct don't do it right
because they need that so that's a good
example another one I have found is the
power of focus I had a call earlier this
hour a guy was asking about stopping his
401k temporarily and missing out on a
the compound interest of that you know
that present value that money also but
but he could also be missing out on the
match right and that's so mathematically
unpalatable it just for a math nerd it
makes this like blasphemy you know and
so but it's a temporary thing and the
power of
getting that income freed up and the
power of the victory of getting the get
you know getting the debt gone and now I
can really hit this investments really
strong and really forcefully does
supersede the missed match on the long
term because we get people able to
invest and then they keep investing when
they invest from a position of weakness
they stop investing every time the
transmission goes out and so they're
jumping in and out in and out of their
investments all the time an example of
that is when we pull up and we're
helping a company change their employees
from the inside we pull up their 401k I
pulled up on the other day the average
employee was putting in thirty two
hundred dollars a year into their 401k
and the average employee had thirty four
hundred dollars in loans right at 401 K
which meant their 401k was useless it
was just they were you know you know so
it's not good to get everybody investing
if they're not able to keep investing
and steadily so that's that's another
one
the third one is and this one just
really blows my mind because it's so
counterintuitive the American
Association of actuaries and pension
planners did a detail piece of research
and they studied retirement success
people who had piles of money at
retirement and they said okay what was
the number one indicator what is the the
the driver of retirement success was
that the asset quality was that the
diversification was that the expense
ratios which are things that you and I
would always look at right you know are
looking at the track record of the
mutual fund or whatever and the number
one driver of retirement success just
like it savings right which means put
money in the investment is the number
one driver and if you can get people
doing that you know it's 74% it was
three-fourths of the cause of someone
winning was that they actually put money
in which is a behavior thing more than
looking at oh well this expense ratio is
different than that expense ratio or
that's a a share or a b share on the
mutual fund or
you know we're doing managed funds or
you know it's a 1% or a half a percent
here or there you know the difference in
the SP or something that's beating the
SP you know that's the kind of crap I
get into and I like but it turns out
that stuff really has a very little
bearing on whether someone succeeds the
main thing that causes them to succeed
is do they put money in which is a
behavior are they actually saving money
and steadily saving money over a long
period of time and so again a the number
one driver of retirement success is the
behavior of actually investing
regardless we don't want to be stupid
and put it in bad stuff you know but but
you know we spend all our time analyzing
all these little minutia things in our
world and it turns out that the big
thing is just getting people to do it
and so if you can do that as a CF as a
certified financial planner you've been
a blessing to your clients if you can
just get them and keep them investing
steadily and you know and you've had
this experience too I'm sure if you've
been doing this a while the market goes
down and you got to talk some of your
clients off the ledge absolutely you
know and and that's a behavior thing
relax
exactly that's a behavior thing that's
not a math thing and I find people are
more apt to invest in equity or more
riskier solutions when they don't have
any debt on the table exactly and say
that that's not a math thing that's a
behavior thing so there's so much of
this stuff that that goes back to that
and we have to just be real careful to
not get paralysis of the analysis on the
mathematics and miss the big things
which is get the people in there keep
them in there and get them moving and if
we do that in your industry and in mind
then we we've done our jobs
hey thanks for stopping by brother no
treble thank you gotta talk to you and a
good question hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
now
[Music]